[Ukraїner
Національні спільноти]
[Катеринівка,
Приазов'я]
Кожен третій тут — грек.
Саме у цьому поселенні.
Навколо дуже багато грецьких поселень.
Я люблю свій район.
Я тут завжди почуваюся у спокої, мені тут добре.
[Богдан Самко,
музикант]
І люди тут!
Ну, якось тут усе по-своєму.
Там такого немає.
Я просто часто бував закордоном.
Це не моє.
Мені подобається в Україні.
Коли заїжджаєш в Україну, це вже свято.
Навіть коли проїжджаєш повз наших...
Як їх називають?
Прикордонників.
Калімера!
[вітаються румейською]
Все чудово.
Ну і нормально.
А ти завтра на Мега Йорти в Волноваху їдеш?
Так, а ти не їдеш?
Йох!
А я не знаю ще, може не вийде.
Мабуть, не вийде. Купа роботи.
О п'ятій ранку підйом,
виганяємо, пасемо.
Приходимо ввечері, десь об 11-12 годині.
Постійно боремося із вовками.
Вночі майже не спиш.
Ну, загалом цілодобово з баранчиками.
Хто, якщо не ми?
Ми повинні займатися цим.
Мій син росте.
Я думаю, він теж пастиме овець.
[Микола Зімбіль,
чабан]
Ну а греки взагалі, вони ж
займаються тваринництвом.
Вони ж переселилися сюди.
Переважно тваринництвом вони займалися,
тому я теж цим займаюся.
Потихеньку, потихеньку
воно відроджується.
Звісно ж, відроджується.
Куди воно дінеться?
Ми сподіваємося на краще.
Ми будемо відроджувати.
Хто, якщо не ми?
І не кажи.
Баранина — це взагалі
перша страва.
Без баранини свята не буває.
Коли на концерти, коли
на день народження запрошують грати,
коли — на весілля.
Завтра буде...
Їдемо в Волноваху.
Грецьке свято називається «Мега Йорти».
У перекладі — «Велике свято».
Його заснував
наш земляк, поет.
Він теж родом з Малоянисоля.
Поет, композитор
Донат Патріча.
І от музична школа, де я працюю,
названа на його честь.
Він її теж, до речі, заснував.
На його честь вона і названа.
І після розпаду Союзу
потихеньку почався
грецький рух у нас в районі.
Зелені верби вздовж ріки,
Співають солов’ї весняні.
Без краю степ, море, горби,
В якій красі живемо!
Тут народились ми й зросли,
Вдихнули запах хлібу,
Тут мову свою зрозуміли,
Побачили, як земля парує.
Ми – твої діти, рідна Україно!
Перейняли традиції твої,
Під небом одним живемо.
У тихі теплі вечори ми пишемо вірші й пісні
Про рідне Приазов’я, дружбу та румеїв
А коротко це про приазовських греків.
Про те, як живуть тут.
Як би нам не було складно тут,
можливо.
Але, у будь-якому випадку, це все своє, рідне.
[Малоянісоль,
Приазов'я]
За паспортом я — грек.
[Василь Папазов,
поет]
Тому що у мене батьки були греками,
і дід, і баба, всі.
Так воно і йде.
Знаю грецьку мову,
а писати — пишу російською.
Мені особисто треба награти.
Я трішки наспівую,
але треба, щоб ти
сам також.
— Ну ви там дуже наспівуйте.
— Включитися, так.
Ми переробили на грецьку лад.
Розмір — сім восьмих.
Треба зробити веселе, запальне.
♪ [співають румейською]
[Волноваха,
Приазов'я]
Починаємо ми відтворювати
стару традиційну.
Я її досі збираю, цю музику.
А потім, як у нас з'явилися поети,
які самі придумують слова,
ми придумуємо музику.
Ми і її граємо,
щоб молодь продовжувала всі традиції:
співали наші пісні,
грали нашу музику.
Це у нас така традиція.
Одна грецька,
слідом — українська.
Потім — грецька,
потім — українська.
Що грек, що українець — це одне і те ж.
Всі ми — українці.
Як не крути.
Я цим дуже пишаюся і радий.
[ ♪ лунає грецька музика ]
Мега Йорти проходить в кож ному селі.
Два роки тому було в Малоянисолі,
тепер — у Волновасі.
Там, де грецьке поселення, там і проходить цей фестиваль.
З'їжджаються греки з усієї України.
Греки з Еллади, гості приїдуть.
У нас живуть у Приазов'ї
румеї і уруми.
Багато поїхали, коли у нас тут...
Почалася оця війна.
Звісно, спочатку було важко.
Ну, а потім
воно більш менш стабілізувалося.
Живемо, як і жили.
Я звідсіля уїзжати не збираюся.
Я тут буду жити,
я тут і помру.
Ото наші стоять?
Да, он Лариса Георгіївна.
Так, все, все.
А тепер ти кажеш...
[говорять румейською]
Разом!
[Греки пов'язані з Україною ще від VIст. до н.е. Вони заснували низку поселень в Криму, ]
[де жили аж до часів завоювання півострова Російською Імперією]
[Наприкінці XVIII ст. за наказом російської імператриці Єкатєріни ІІ]
[кримських греків виселили на територію сучасного Приазов'я]
[Більша частина спільноти і тепер мешкає тут.]
[Попри значну асиміляцію та наслідки утисків з боку Російської імперії та Радянського Союзу,]
[приазовські греки зберігають власну культуру і відновлюють загрожені мови:]
[урумську та румейську, які є унікальним надбанням українських греків]
[Автор проекту
Богдан Логвиненко]
[Режисерка монтажу
Марія Теребус]
[Продюсерка
Оля Шор]
[Звукорежисер
Павло Пашко]
[Режисер
Микола Носок]
[Оператори
Марія Теребус, Олег Марчук]
[Субтитрувальниця
Валерія Діденко]
[Ukraїner
Національні спільноти]
[Серія відео створена за підтримки Агенства США з міжнародного розвитку (USAID)]